let's talk about what to expect tomorrow
night with the results specifically
about the house joining us now House
Speaker Paul Ryan he's in Janesville
Wisconsin mr. speaker thanks for being
here this is the first time you are not
on the ballot since 1998 you are
finishing this campaign where you
started it in southern Wisconsin in that
district you've represented since then
so your sense of tonight and where it's
heading tomorrow yeah you know I
actually feel good I've been
crisscrossing not just Wisconsin but
America I've spent the last three weeks
in 12 states and 50 cities campaigning
with our members in the toughest races
frankly our members feel pretty good
because they have a really good message
Brett I mean look at what we have just
been able to achieve in Congress with
the president in the last two years a
record economy the military being
rebuilt people feeling better about
things more jobs being offered in
America today than people looking for
jobs wages growing faster than they have
since before the recession and because
of all of this our candidates feel like
they have a great message and the
alternative is the chaos and the
dysfunction in Washington that the
Democrats are basically promising if
they get control of Congress so we
really feel like we got a good shot at
keeping our majority because our record
is so good and the contrast is so strong
mr. speaker Politico reported that you
called president Trump's Sunday to plead
with him to focus on the economy in the
closing argument is that true it
wouldn't surprise you that they don't
get these things exactly right and this
is no exception
look he and I talk all the time we
compare notes on the campaign trail
we've been speaking repeatedly
throughout this campaign cycle in just
the last few weeks so we're always
comparing notes about the campaign about
messaging he frankly called me to see
how certain members were doing because
he cares about a lot of our members we
can do both look people do care about
national security we want a secure
border let's really clear the Democrats
when I abolish ice it's ridiculous and
we do think we should be talking about
our strong economy because it's been
spectacular and the Democrats are
talking about rolling back and raising
taxes more spending they're proposing to
basically undo all the good progress
that we've been having I would simply
ask people do you feel better today than
you did two years ago if so get out and
vote tomorrow that is what the president
I've been talking about and we can talk
more than one issue but we really do
have a very good story to tell in the
economy of our wages about jobs about
opportunities and how about how people
feel about them and we think it's a
really good story to tell about taxes
you obviously passed a major tax reform
bill and passed the House passed the
Senate made it to the President's desk
here's the president on tax cuts on the
campaign trail take a listen we're going
to be putting in a 10% tax cut for
middle-income families it's going to be
[Applause]
[Music]
so we sang in addition to the first
round to do a second round 10% tax cut
for the middle class the specifics of
that never came out before tomorrow was
there a specific plan is there a
specific plan yeah I've spoken with the
president number of times about this as
has Kevin Brady our chairman of the Ways
and Means Committee my old job and so we
talked about this and we passed in the
house already
bill making the family tax relief
provisions of small business tax relief
provisions permanent and what the
president wants to do is on tax reform
2.0 in the next session of Congress is
to go at it again and give the
middle-class tax relief so that's what
he's been talking about we agree we
think that's something that Congress in
the next session should work on so we
think we've made great progress the
economy is growing extremely well
largely because of tax cuts and tax
reform and so the president wants to
have another kick at its to keep this
economy growing I think that's a good
idea but so far it's not a specific plan
that's going to be rolled out or
something no I mean that's the way tax
laws work the Ways and Means Committee
can come up with many different ways of
getting a 10% tax cut on income taxes
for middle income taxpayers and by the
way there are ways of doing it on a
revenue neutral basis that's something
that they're going to work through the
process at the beginning of the next
session of Congress all right the other
thing that obviously you were in the
news recently is this back and forth on
birthright citizenship the president
saying he could do it possibly with an
executive order you said that that was
not the case you were asked about that
on the trail the president then tweeted
out after seeing that Paul Ryan should
be focusing on holding the majority
rather than giving his opinions on
birthright citizenship something he
knows nothing about our new Republican
majority will work on this closing the
immigration loopholes and securing our
border what about that miss speaker it's
all good like I said he and I have a
very long very very good relationship we
talked that day later on look I was
commenting on the means not the merits I
think we should review this especially
for illegals and people getting a
tourist visa coming over just to have a
kid that's something we should look at
because this is the 21st century it's
not the 18th century when that was
written but what I was commenting on are
the constitutional means of achieving
something like that I
it's either a constitutional amendment
or statutory change that would be
required not an executive order an
executive order could force a court
challenge but I don't think an executive
order could actually make the change
that has to be either constitutional or
at very least statutory so I was
basically talking about a constitutional
process the legal process on achieving
something but should we look at whether
or not in the 21st century someone
coming over with a tourist visa just for
the sake of having a baby here to then
get citizenship yeah I think that's
something that should be reviewed mr.
speaker you spent the last three weeks
in 50 cities 12 states campaigning with
25 different House members you raised
200 million plus hard dollars over the
past three years for this effort if the
house flips tomorrow why will that have
happened history is not our friend and
what I mean when I say that Bret is the
historic average for a midterm election
for a president's party in the
president's first midterm is 32 seats we
have a 23 seat majority a couple of our
seats are already gone because of recent
redistricting that was done in say
Pennsylvania
so we already are standing against a
historical trend that cuts against us
but the reason I feel like this is going
to be really really close and I feel
cautiously optimistic is because of our
record we have done so much we passed
over a thousand bills in the house in
just the last two years making a huge
difference
tackling opioids human trafficking
rebuilding the military overhauling the
VA deregulating the economy creating
jobs and jobs and wages and overhauling
the tax system among many other things
so it's been an enormous record of
accomplishment most objective Americans
would see that that the country is so
much better off than it was just two
years ago and they don't want to see the
Democrats Nancy Pelosi take power to
bring chaos and gridlock to Washington
they'll try to impeach the president
they want to abolish eyes--and and
that's the agency that guards our border
that stops drugs from coming into our
country and they want socialized
medicine which which will be a disaster
for our country plus a thirty two
trillion dollar tax increase to pay for
it so I think the contrast is clear
that's why I think we got a really good
chance because history although it's not
our friend we
good record that can help come about
that last thing quickly mr. speaker I've
covered you for a long time I covered
you as vice-presidential nominee in
which you made the case numerous times
on the trail and in your acceptance
speech that we can't spend money that we
don't have that the debt crisis is going
to hit us eventually this year the
federal deficits are seven hundred
seventy nine billion dollars CBA CBO is
projecting nine hundred and seventy
three billion for 2019 one trillion for
2020 is that going to be addressed it
has to be addressed in Bret none of
those numbers are surprise to anybody
the CBO has been telling this for years
and it's because of demographics the
baby boomers are retiring and we're not
ready for them I would note that the
house did pass health care reform
legislation which in addition to
guaranteeing protections for people with
pre-existing conditions would have given
people more choices lowered premiums but
it also would have been a great effort a
debt reduction the House passed that
bill it was the biggest debt reduction
bill we've considered in a generation
the biggest entitlement reform bill we
considered in the generation
unfortunately it failed to pass the
Senate by one vote
so I think Congress needs to get back at
that because we do need health care
reform we need to lower premiums we need
to maintain those protections for
pre-existing conditions as our bill did
do but you also have to deal with these
these issues you also on the flip side
Brett you've got to have a growing
economy more people working paying taxes
keeping revenues up that's happening
because we've done what we need to do to
get this economy growing there's more to
do but we've done a great job on that so
on the entitlement side yes that's
something that's got to get done are you
sad you're not on the ballot you know
it's bittersweet I'm excited about the
guy who's running Bryan style running
for my seat I think he's gonna do a
spectacular job I think he's gonna win
I've been Ron a bus the last couple of
days with my governor Scott Walker
he's got a really tough race here so I'm
right now I'm sort of thinking about the
people I care about I want to see win
there are a lot of my colleagues in
Congress who are really tough races that
have just that deserved in earned
re-election and I want to make sure that
those guys get get elected that's pretty
much my focus but yeah it's a little
bittersweet I've been doing this for 20
years this is the tenth election cycle
so the first time since 1998 I've never
been on a ballot so yeah it's a little
bittersweet mr. speaker we appreciate
your your
tonight you bet take care Brett